the meg was directed by Jon Turteltaub
and stars Jason Statham as a marine
diving expert who must face off against
a Megalodon a prehistoric shark 70 feet
in length that attacks an underwater
research facility so Jason Statham and
his team of awesome people have to band
together to hopefully kill this thing
before it reaches the shores so
Hollywood has been obsessed with sharks
ever since Jaws in 1975 but Hollywood
has taken a far more serious approach to
shark movies as of late with movies like
47 meters down or the shallows these
were very serious films that were meant
to be dramatic and very frightening and
scary at the same time straight to TV
straight to DVD or blu-ray or video on
demand shark films like snow sharks sand
sharks mega sharks octopus sharks and of
course the sharknado films have embraced
a more lighthearted silly and self-aware
approach and with the Meg Hollywood has
embraced this notion as well and thrown
150 million dollars and Jason Statham at
an incredibly silly shark film that I
had a great time watching this is by no
means some incredible film that's going
to be remembered for years as some
achievements but no one really expected
it to be this film is pretty much
exactly what I was hoping for a shark
film that knows what it is that isn't
trying to be some serious masterpiece
it's not trying to compete with Jaws it
has tons of Jaws references the film has
just enough characterization to make you
care particularly with Statham's
character he's tried to get people to
believe that this thing exists for years
at the cost of his own career and so the
thing resurfacing and him being like hey
I was I was telling you about that
shock you you it I'm a fan
of Jason Statham I like him in tons of
movies I always find him a very likable
presence and he's no stranger to water
England's Jason Statham his forward
three-and-a-half somersault with tuck
this role was definitely right up his
alley and so there's some fun to be had
with the characters there's some
confrontations that I actually enjoyed
there's an adorable little girl in this
film that has some really fun interplay
with Statham and even though the film
does try to have a romance and kind of
get you invested in other things I'm
just waiting for the shark you could go
and see the Meg and leave saying like
wow that was so bad for so many reasons
and you could really get invested in in
hating this movie about a giant shark
with Jason Statham or you can just
accept what they're going for and enjoy
the ride but I do have one major
complaint
I feel like this film really would have
benefited from a rated R rating
Eli Roth was originally going to direct
the film and he wanted to rate it our
rating and the studio wanted pg-13 and
and while there's there's tons of like
shark blood and other animal deaths and
stuff and some human blood this film
could have been a lot more entertaining
and even more tongue-in-cheek if there
was more gore involved which would have
been a far more entertaining film but
that's really my only real complaint
here beyond the obvious
it's a 1990s movie without a doubt this
film belongs in 1997 if it came out in
97 it would have starred Nicolas Cage in
his prime Conair mode and it would have
been a blast and people would talk about
how much they liked it nowadays if you
really want to get serious about the
70-foot shark movie the characterization
could be so much better some of the
performances are weak a lot of the
characters are just your stereotypical
versions of other characters we've seen
the rich guy who owns the place who
jokes every once in a while and and and
they make him be like this really
larger-than-life character you have the
side characters that are there just to
tell jokes the little girl who's meant
to be adorable the the woman who's there
clearly just to be a romantic interest
but she can do some stuff too and then
you have you're expendable people who
are obviously just meant to be eaten I
mean you understand how it works
it's just that this film is more
entertaining than others because it also
understands how silly it is and embraces
that and in so doing I had a really good
time watching the Meg I'm gonna give it
a B if you enjoy watching silly shark
films on VOD or on the sci-fi channel
but you
we're hoping that Hollywood would make
one with really good visual effects and
a high budget and jason statham
well you'll probably enjoy the meg but
certainly do not go into the film
expecting some masterpiece because
you're going to be disappointed but I
really don't think anyone's going to
guys thank you so much as always for
watching please look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
the nice
[Music]